hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about how to reverse
atherosclerosis that's Harding of your
arteries now typically people have this
idea that this problem comes purely from
consuming too much cholesterol
okay so let's kind of dissect really
what happens here's an artery there's
always a pre-existing lesion or crack in
the artery before this whole chain of
event occurs is some micro hemorrhaging
and what happens is the cholesterol
comes in there as a band-aid to heal the
the bleeding crack in your arteries so
that's what that's one big purpose of
cholesterol and it actually works with
calcium to form a like a little band-aid
and what causes the lesion or the crack
is usually either a low vitamin C
situation because the person is not
consuming enough vegetables okay that's
number one because vitamin C and I'm not
talking about the synthetic vitamin C
I'm talking about real vitamin C in its
whole complex because vitamin C in the
complex has a factor it's a type of
copper in an enzyme form called
tyrosinase which basically helps you
form collagen okay so if you don't have
that factor you get a lot of cracks and
problems in the vascular system okay
loss of collagen everything becomes very
rigid so we need the vitamin C from the
vegetables okay the other thing that
will cause it would be high insulin
because the person consumes too much
sugar or refined carbohydrates that can
also cause inflammation and micro
hemorrhaging so we have this lesion the
body comes in forms a little plaquing
things to try to protect it with
cholesterol and by the way cholesterol
will also go way up with insulin in fact
unless you have a genetic problem with
cholesterol which is very rare
I will bet anything your cholesterol is
coming from too much insulin so if you
were to cut out all the carbs like we're
fine carbs and sugars and alcohol that
cholesterol will come down faster than
anything would probably within a month
okay that's just the side down so here
we got this combination of
straw and calcium plaquing and then what
happens is that it starts getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and it creates
like a clogging of an artery okay now
other things that can cause this calcium
buildup would be taking too much calcium
in the wrong form especially let's say
you were taking calcium carbonate that
is limestone that is cement okay then
you actually added with vitamin D
calcium with vitamin D you know a
vitamin D does it actually helps you
absorb calcium in the gut by 20 times
okay
not not by 20 a percent 20x so you're
absorbing all this calcium and the blood
is filling up with calcium that's kind
of calls quote what's called
hypercalcemia so the combination of this
vitamin d with calcium which so many
people are taking as a supplement
because you get tested by the doctor he
says your low vitamin D so you start
taking it you add some calcium in there
right and you think you're doing
yourself some good but what happens is
you're just filling up the harder for
use with calcium especially if you don't
have the magnet magnesium because
magnesium helps to buffer the calcium as
well so what's missing in this whole
picture well in order for you to have
vitamin D work correctly in calcium you
need another vitamin called vitamin k2
you've never heard about this you need
to do some research I've put some links
below so you can watch some more data on
k2 but vitamin k2 probably in the next
few years will be very very mainstream
because what it does it basically
removes calcium from the soft tissues of
the body it helps to clean up the
calcification on the arteries it
basically prevents your arteries turning
into bone and stone
it makes your arteries more elastic it's
really good for blood pressure so k2
well guess where you get vitamin k2 it's
in it's a fat Seibel vitamin so it's in
all the fats that the doctor has been
telling you to avoid it's in cheese it's
an egg yolk
st. grass-fed fatty meats it's also in a
soy product called NATO that's a Japan
dish but mainly it's in the fats so here
the person is consuming a low-fat diet
their arteries are clogged they put them
on coumadin and by the way blocks
vitamin k1 so now you can't eat the
vegetables where you gonna get your
vitamin C from you take it from a pill
it's usually going to be synthetic so
you're going to take the synthetic
vitamin C which will actually aggravate
everything so it really is is messed up
what we need to do is we need to if
you're uncommitted you need to take the
right amount of vegetables okay I have a
video on that if you want to see that
that our low vitamin K get the vitamin C
heal this original thing start taking
vitamin k2 you can take d3 and you can
probably even take some calcium but
probably not a good idea unless you have
cramps in your calves that's a good
indication you need calcium but most
people can get it from the food because
you're eating these foods right here
like cheese that's going to give you
enough calcium I think the only time
that I recommend a calcium supplement is
typically if the person has cramps in
the calves or they've osteoporosis or
osteopenia okay I'd like to get that one
from the food but vitamin D is important
as well but we need to vitamin k2 okay
so if you were to do these things reduce
the insulin take the vegetables advocate
to avoid the calcium you'll be in pretty
good shape and you can create some nice
change over time and by the way the
people that are taking any assets well
they're getting the calcium carbonate
you'll be better off June I'm gonna
cement down the street you know alright
so I threw a lot at you hope this helped
and I will see you in the next video hey
guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video